hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand lie waifu
and we have all sorts of surprises for
you today including a special guest
intrigued let's get into the episodes
because
i was intrigued episode 86 this episode
was
on the whole some comic relief after the
depth of disaster that's been happening
this arc
since i'm watching two episodes per week
it felt a bit weird and i didn't know
what to expect when i got what i got
once i remembered that kite is most
certainly dead
definitely dead right he's not encased
in a sleeping beauty tomb because he's
going to be brought back to tragically
have to fight gon and keela in a battle
where his clown friend becomes more
menacing
and laughs evilly and tries to take them
out with a good choice in weapon
right he's gonna be able to pull through
and sacrifice himself again to protect
the kids because that's what kite would
have done
in life he's a good guy in fact thinking
about it he's probably one of the best
they've met
besides a little sushi roll so yeah
there's no need to worry about the
darkness of kite taking over and burning
everything to the ground
or nitero being weak because he's old or
that he fully agrees with kilwa about
his you know abilities against python
yes i've changed their names it's much
easier if i have
python because i know what a python is
it's a little stick that you hammer into
them
look y'all there is nothing to be afraid
of don't be
afraid i know i'm not at all not even
concerned because you know a number of
these characters have plot armor so they
can't even die it's not possible
kite was introduced for the purpose of
sacrifice so he always knew he would but
the others
natera especially takashi seems to like
the tarot so he couldn't kill him right
i mean
beside his interest in tatars he's
generally an okay guy who
cares about the desires of our kids and
speaking of the kids
it's weird but the framing of this
episode suggests they're now subplot
status
their training and development as
characters seem very secondary to the
real story which still feels like it's
happening back at the ant hill with pito
the new friend they've gained palm
i don't actually know what to think
about this character she's just
weird good weird bad weird i don't know
just weird i don't have any particular
attachment or aversion to her either i
feel kind of neutral which usually tells
me that i don't have enough
understanding of why she should or could
be significant
at the moment she's just a side
character tagashi had in his head and
decided to ram into this episode because
he was bored which is very takashi like
i suppose the way we hang on to palm
stalkery behavior just
long enough to note she's weird but
brush past anything that could actually
be of input in what she's saying
such as that her desire to get to her
teacher will lead her to ultimately kill
them
not important either that's what they're
doing anyway or they have no concern
that they could defeat her and so why
does she exist
and while she's artistically interesting
her premise is a little worn to me and
you know then again she's also from the
90s so maybe she's the reason it feels
worn in 2020.
speaking of warn let's extrapolate that
a little because there were a lot of
things that felt fillery about this
episode the first was the amount of time
they sat at a table eating
let's see sandwiches no they're on a bed
of salad so
no they're on a bed of sand no they're
on a bed of salad sandwiches
they spent a disorder amount of time
discussing the situation while eating a
sandwich salad because look at the
number of sandwich halves that is a
sandwich salad and a plate of really
simple pasta and while i think it's
great that we know these kids are
getting their carbs in it was such a
static scene that it was
visually boring and in fact i'm sure
they were talking about something useful
but i don't know what it was because i
had to stop and look at the sandwich
salad so even if the information they
were providing was supposed to be of
narrative interest i wasn't interested
in it and you know what it reminded me
of
there are scenes in every disney or
pixar
or disney pixar because they bought the
movie that is designed at about
halfway through the movie where nothing
at all happens
it's the kids break right that's what it
is it's a kid's bathroom break if i'd
been watching one episode a week i'd
have been so
i don't know kind of disappointed with
this episode
the only thing that really made me perk
up in the first half was palm
saying love is a spontaneous thing don't
you think
and i loved that it was kilwa kilwa of
course wearing a new
shirt because of course he would a
little fashionista and it was he
who interrupted i adore that he needs to
take
everyone's mind away from love
particularly unrequited
love before anyone else could see that
he's also
experiencing it foregone the one beside
him who has no idea that he loves him
oh when will my husband return from war
it's that kind of vibe you know moving
on knucklehead is the most absurd
creature i've ever seen and the idea
that they need to take him seriously
frustrates me more and i'm not
sure why exactly but it has something to
do with the way he issued his challenge
i understand that he could turn out to
be super powerful but i also feel as
though they're past the point of dealing
with people and that
lack of professionality right like you
you tell people where you're gonna be
and then you like yeah it's annoying i'm
sure that was supposed to be the charm
of it but that's not what i saw
experience then let's move on biski's
back biski's back back
again and we finally got to see her
magical girl massaging clone cookie
it was in every sense of the word a
cookie day
i'm hoping we get back to the main story
post biscuit and cookie day because i'm
hoping the next arc will be about a gon
who travels to the underworld to bring
kite back
and i would legitimately watch the hell
out of that something i did notice about
this episode was such a dramatic shift
in both
line art and inktone that it felt as
though some of the animators on it
changed or the technology
used to animate the show changed
mid-episode was there a hiatus
mid episode around halfway through the
lines got heavier as though they
switched to full digital but i'm fairly
sure
they'd have been digital way earlier if
not from the start so i'm not
sure what i'm seeing here the art just
looks significantly different and i
couldn't let that pass without a mention
because it pulled me out of the story to
look
at the storytelling for a bit with two
months or so to the birth of the king
we finally get to our celebrity who's
that celebrity
it's shia labeouf yay
shia labeouf soon to be joined by
menthol
i have no idea what their names are
supposed to be but menthol
and shia labeouf seem appropriate with
the other bizarre things that happen in
the story
he even looks a little like our good
friend shire in no way at all
let's find out what they'll do in
episode 87. apparently in episode 87
we're doing our best to exterminate the
ants one squadron at a time or at least
that's what the pros are trying to do
meanwhile gone and killer are doing
whatever they must to save kite
so here's the thing we're really
drumming the idea that gon is doing all
this to save kite right home with a
sledgehammer it's really drummond at
home like really tagashi wants to make
sure we know that's the reason god's
doing all this i mean
i imagine it might i'm not sure but it
might be super important that he believe
he can save someone who we know was
beheaded and is now
locked in a crystal cage because of how
hard they're pushing the inevitable
outcome of that experience for gone
it means the tension's being stepped out
of it and
instead a lot of the tension we're
getting from episodes at the moment is
from knowing that the queen is growing
and now moving king
on the outside of her body so she's
managed to lay the king egg and if we
zoom in on that
oh yep looks like he's gonna be born
with the hat and that's not concerning
in any way i can't even imagine giving
birth to a fully clothed baby but you
know what it would save a lot of money
to do so
250 human meatballs and you know the
idea that pregnant people need to eat
for two is incorrect it can actually be
quite unhealthy for both parent and baby
if it's not a healthy diet so maybe she
should slow down
especially with the human because it
tends to be such a rich meat
i hope she has a good midwife and a
solid medical plan because since this
thing started she's eaten a whole lot of
exotic creatures
and i have concerns biscuit as usual is
uh
reading sexy romantic magazines while
gone and killa learned to keep their ren
going for three hours
this episode and the whole knucklehead
situation felt immediately more
like the filler that we got before and
you know what i get it i do get it the
show
can't be dark for too long or people
disconnect because of the oversaturation
of traumatizing information
you need to break it up with
wholesomeness in order to feel truly
feel
the impact of the awful things to come
and that explains the absurdly cute
doe-eyed dog that follows knuckle around
though because of the darkness that
we've had so far i really kind of
expected
i don't know for knuckle to just like
kick it or for it to like fall off a
cliff or something i don't i really kind
of expected that
i did not think that dog would be
surviving and i still don't know what to
make of him
knucklehead not the dog i love the dog
dogs are great dog dog dog i don't find
knuckle lovable enough to get over the
idiocy that kilowatt notes and i think
that's because i personally have low
tolerance for things that don't bear
relevance to the situation as i'm seeing
it and i'm still not convinced that
either palm
or knuckle both parts of the hand i
notice
i'm still not convinced they're anywhere
near the ability level of the boys
despite what's been shown and i feel
that's either
a basic storytelling flaw or we're going
to experience the old
switcheroo the story of the power
comparison has been told in the way
gone and kilwa react to them and in the
way biski reacts to the whole situation
their reaction suggests just how
concerned i should be and it's pretty
clear the answer right now
is that i shouldn't be so i'm not
resulting in drop tension despite
knowing the idea is to train
up to be able to take on one of the
royal guards perhaps it's simply that i
don't see
any of the current human creatures as
powerful enough to deal with them and so
the entire training process just kind of
feels
not pointless but maybe lesser i'm not
sure knuckle's assumptions about why
people would want to find and fight him
the assumptions he makes about their
presence at all and the way
all of that comes out in his internal
thoughts describes a serious amount of
anxiety and insecurity about how
powerful he actually is
since gone is too steamy brained to
really consider how powerful he is
before he tries to fight someone
and kilwa carefully considers situations
before he acts there are a number of
things
they do that suggest they think he's
strong but again we don't have that
information so i feel i'm left in a sort
of
limbo what is important is that the
other assassin they have to take out is
likely going to be more powerful than
knuckle and that's fine but we're not
there yet and because i'm desperate to
know what happens next in the moon arc
this feels like a lesser destruction
that said what i did expect was for them
to have the same outcome as when they
first trained with biscuit and caught a
serial killer
that they would simply torture him until
both of them could comfortably take him
on but they're at the beginning of the
process and
both need to fight him together suggest
he is definitely more powerful so yeah i
don't know what's going on with my
perception
speaking of more powerful we still
haven't seen a terror fight in earnest
and i
want that i want to see what he does and
how he tries to bring down these ants
that he's fighting one-on-one at the
moment i'm
really interested in this virtual space
and the way the punitive crew
are breaking the fight down to make it
manageable the problem is that we know
how many ants there are and that the
more powerful ones are going to have nem
so i'm
ready for that the royal guard are
already showing how they live
outside of the structure that exists i
get the sense they don't care about the
queen and on a certain level i wonder
what they actually think of the king
they're going to be protecting because
python's already undertaking their own
experiments
i'm really enjoying the development of
those i now consider the main
protagonist of the story and it happens
so steadily that change from
you know antagonist to protagonist that
i kind of don't care that my perspective
has changed so drastically i really
don't know how they've managed to build
a lab or how pito got hold of the
materials to genetically modify a kite
but i guess kite won't need to worry
about being powerful
is pito rebuilding him to fight again or
to unleash him against others
porque no los dos i guess there are a
lot of traps being set up and sprung and
i guess we're going to
get to meet the grumpy shadowed edgelord
next episode there's only one way to
find out but it's not right now because
that's it from me
if you enjoyed the things that you've
heard and the things that i've said
and then the the click here because why
not
it'll be fun join us on the discord and
have fun with stuff and have a great
week and eat stuff and drink lots of
water and i'll see you next time